how much money do i have let's say you  got 50 grand what's your thoughts if you  were coming into this again post covey  what would you do tomorrow it depends on  who i am and what my skill set is be  really difficult to open a facility and  market it with that kind of money so i  probably would try and learn online if  that's all i had starting online is  probably the only place that would make  sense because there's lower barrier to  entry that being said there's more  competition so you have to be willing to  either have a superior skill set which  would be understanding the marketing  side of paid acquisition which takes  time and money to understand or having  the work ethic to  do outbound for you know two to four  hours a day every day to build up my  business if you have the skill set  being online in general will make you  more money the big if is if you have the  skill set